ah bonjour à régis alors la famille
d'olivier dubois dénonça incidence
insupportable on sait que c'est toujours
compliqué d'informer les familles dans
les affaires de prises d'otages par des
djihadistes au sahel pour autant comment
expliquer l'absence totale d'information
que dénoncent les proches d'olivier
dubois
a écouté le fait d'abord olivier dubois
et le dernier faut le rappeler le
dernier otages français dans le monde et
à ce titre c'est vrai que plus
d'attention devrait être mis sur lui et
plus d'efforts sans doute fait pour sa
libération on imagine que les services
du quai d'orsay et beaucoup
d'intermédiaires au mali également sont
à l'oeuvre pour essayer de tout faire
pour le libérer il y à une partie comme
vous l'avez préciser ses vrais dans les
affaires d'otages qui est compliqué
c'est à dire cette partie où dire ou ne
pas dire dire veut parfois dire mettre
en danger potentiellement la vie de
l'otage donc il ya on marche sur des
oeufs à chaque fois et c'est très très
compliqué néanmoins ce qu'il faut c'est
continuer à faire en sorte que olivier
dubois qu'on parle d'olivier dubois est
autrement que dans les simples cercle
journalistique reporters sans frontières
et est mobilisé un certain nombre de nos
confrères nous ça me touche énormément
parce que c'est un journaliste qui a été
enlevé en faisant son métier en allant
sur le terrain donc c'est quelqu'un qui
est comme nous et une qui a pris ces
risques là et qui est aujourd'hui détenu
privée de liberté donc nous ça nous
concerne parce que c'est notre métier et
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
parallèle qui qui fait ce métier mais il
faut que la mobilisation soit bien plus
importante quelque part pour montrer
justement qu'on n'oublie pas que ça ne
reste pas quelqu'un comme ça ça fait
neuf mois qu'il est aux mains de jean
denim neuf mois qu'il est détenu dans un
coin du sahel et il faut évidemment
parlé avec évidemment les précautions
nécessaires à prendre est ce que on peut
imaginer que le contexte d'instabilité
politique actuelle au mali compliquer
les choses
oui il le compliqué en même temps les
autorités françaises et les autorités
maliennes travail les deux ajustements à
la libération d'olivier les maliens ont
de leur côté des contacts que les
français n'ont pas donc il ya une
processus au mali entamée depuis
longtemps de dialogue avec des groupes
jihadistes on sait que ces négociations
allaient pu permettre la libération de
sophie près petrona et de souleymane
cissé il ya environ un an
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce que voilà les
les contacts malien permettront
justement peut-être d'avancer davantage
en tout cas les deux pistes sont
ouvertes et deborah al masri mam a
précisé qu'elle était consciente
justement du fait que et le mali et la
france faisait tout ce qui était en leur
pouvoir justement pour qu'olivier soit
retrouve sa liberté alors vous avez cité
sophie petronas que la faire à son fils
petrona a refroidi d'une certaine
manière à les autorités française
enlevée en 2016 au mali sophie pétrole
un a été libéré en octobre 2020 avant de
retourner à bamako ce que les autorités
françaises ont jugé d'ailleurs
irresponsable alors la sphère petronas
la faire scission
pardonnez-moi staps us mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est devenu
comment de l'ordre d'un problème en
effet quand une personne est libéré et
qu' elle décide de revenir dans le pays
où elle a été enlevée et potentiellement
sur les lieux ou en tout cas là où elle
vivait pas très loin de son lieu de
détention ça pose un problème ce qui
pose surtout un problème c'est qu'un
certain nombre de personnes ont été
libérés en échange justement de la
libération ce type et rona mère
rappelons aussi que se fit pas de
pétrole 1 n'est pas la seule otage avoir
été libéré et l'homme politique dont
souleymane cissé lui était un homme
politique d'envergure au mali et ses 8
principalement qui était visé par cette
libération
cette libération était conditionné à la
libération des prisons maliennes de 200
djihadistes ces djihadistes avaient été
arrêtés
pour partie par les soldats de barkan
certains ont été blessés voire tuer pour
arrêter ces djihadistes donc il y a eu
effectivement un émoi dans l'armée
française et donc parmi les autorités
françaises quand ce type et prône un a
décidé de quitter sa résidence en suisse
pour revenir clandestinement d'une
certaine façon au mali dans le pays où
elle avait été détenu et et surtout
peut-être potentiellement risqué d'être
capturé à nouveau alors actuellement à
l'étape à macau elle n'est pas revenue
dans son lieu dans le lieu où elle dit
vais donc il ya moins de risques mais en
tout cas c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui a posé problème qui a posé un
problème moral pour un problème aussi
aux autorités françaises je ne pense pas
qu'ils fassent corrélés et que la
situation d'olivier dubois aujourd'hui
avec celle de sophie petronas et de
choses qui ont complètement rien à voir
et les cadeaux ta justement se négocient
au cas par cas là on est avec des
groupes différents on est avec des
dynamiques différents et une situation
qui est différent mais qui est traitée a
pas
alors sur le site touch points mais donc
cette pétition et dans un communiqué la
famille indique un vouloir alerter
certes les citoyens français mais aussi
les chefs d'état français et malien
justement on est on approche d'une
échéance en france importante élection
présidentielle est ce qu'on peut espérer
une réaction peut-être d'emmanuel macron
et voire même libération dans une
prochainement là c'est très difficile à
dire il faut il faut voir où en sont les
négociations qu est ce que veut qu'est
ce que veulent les jeunes humains le
groupe de l'iliade al ghali actuellement
qui détient olivier dubois c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile à
anticiper il est évident que faire un
effort supplémentaire pour la libération
d'un otage dans une veille d'élection ne
peut pas faire de mal au président
sortant je ne pense pas non plus que
l'on puisse dire qu'ils le kick il n'y a
pas fait libérer avant et qui va le
faire juste pour la présidentielle il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas de corrélation de
cette date de cette nature actuellement
les négociations si elles existent parce
que la question aussi c'est que le
groupe en question donc les jeux nîmes
très peu communiqué on sait que olivier
dubois a fait comment diffuser à lui a
permis de diffuser une vidéo au début de
son emprise de sa capture en avril
dernier dans laquelle il admettait il
reconnaissait avoir été être otages et
être détenus depuis il n'y a eu aucun
aucune communication vidéo vidéo où
aucune aucun message radiophonique
enregistré attestant justement de 2 2 à
2 la delà de l'avis de lier on sait
qu'il est il ya eu des informations
qu'ils ont et qui ont filtré de la part
de groupes djihadistes qui ont admis
qu'ils avaient dans leurs oeufs
qu'il était en détention s'il se met en
dehors de ça il ya eu très très peu
d'informations communiquer c'est une
affaire compliquée ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est que ce journaliste qui faisait son
métier qui étaient sur le terrain qui
inlassablement à toujours justement
pratiquer ce journaliste de sources en
allant vers les gens en allant
communiqué et en allant sur le terrain
puissent recouvrer sa liberté le plus
rapidement possible merci beaucoup avoue
régis le sommier je rappelle que votre
entretien avec la compagne d'olivier
dubois est à retrouver sur rt france